місця золото на луганщині
люди прийшли за гуманітарною допомогою
він солідних надії возняк вона разом
закликала engineering а ми факти що
замінило мера місця тієї в тег коли
розгойдалася шпалер ідеї золото просто шо
ви на прямо на лінії фронту обстріли з
бійська
влітку до труби натягнути і там просто
вдих сухих буки вам було тобі буду і ніг
миша continues to open і вася між двома
вогнів з одного боку
українські весь кави син шева бойовики я
взагалі ми відпочиваємо ася абсолютно
турботами
симов ключ на проглодала якщо 2 роки провини
руїну ваня тут на шкірному укрийте
снаряд у променях і всю квартиру тпр вид
холоду захищаючи найкращий пластик на повіках
наша знімали на гурт та деталі де
вартість зупиніть луганській
ланцюг від контроль на Україні територія
єдиними стінами пивну регіону ти можна
стрибнути і кордон з окупованими
районами
люди приїжджають сюди на автобусах обидва
велосипедах по тій воді нам із чоловіка
Чика ти в межах шалених прийшли збоку так
званої лнр за пенсію душі вам
продуктами і paratis ти мене звуть
сепаратистам і я вдома нічого про ти
україни та росії
ми жили мирно і все було добре, а зараз
хто з робіна з ворогами на вигляд ми нею
владну гарматну я не можемо поїхати в
гості до своїх братів та сестер ці
живуть у лева vi і sta-2 рок і війни на
сході україна яга забрала жити апу над 8
тисяч людей ніхто не знаючи, що зможе
нового примиріться і збитки сторона
конфлікту